I'M LAURA INGRAHAM THIS IS THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM AN VERY BUSY
WASHINGTON TONIGHT WE GET RIGHT
TO IT.
OUR INCREDIBLE SHRINKING
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
JOE BIDEN THOUGHT THAT HE WOULD
WIPE AWAY THE NATIONAL DISGRACE
OF HIS AFGAN WITHDRAW BY
ADDRESSING THE NATION WITH AN
ANGRY AND HECTORING TONE TODAY.
>> WE REACHED OUT 19 TIMES TO
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN WITH
MULTIPLE WARNINGS.
THE DECISION TO LIFT MILITARY
OPERATIONS AT KABUL AIRPORT WAS
BASED ON THE UNANIMOUS
RECOMMENDATION OF MY CIVILIAN
AND MILITARY ADVISORS.
THEIR RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT
THE STATE PERSUADE AND SECURE
THE PASSAGE OF THE REMAINING
AMERICANS AND OTHERS OUT OF THE
COUNTRY WAS NOT TO CONTINUE WITH
6,000 TROOPS ON THE GROUND IN
HARM'S WAY IN KABUL, BUT RATHER
TO GET THEM OUT THROUGH
NON-MILITARY MEANS.
.
>> LAURA: LESS THAN TWO WEEKS
AGO, BIDEN SAID WE'D STAY UNTIL
EVERY AMERICAN GOT OUT OF THE
COUNTRY BUT TODAY, HE CLAIMED
LEAVING 10% BEHIND WAS A WIN.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE?
90% OF AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN
WHO WANTED TO LEAVE WERE ABLE TO
LEAVE.
SECRETARY OF STATE BLINKEN IS
LEADING THE CONTINUED DIPLOMATIC
EFFORTS TO ENSURE SAFE PASSAGE
FOR ANY AMERICAN WHO WANTS TO
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
>> LAURA: JOE BIDEN THOUGHT HE
WOULD REVERSE THE PUBLIC'S
GROWING DISTRUST OF HIS
PRESIDENCY WITH BRAGGING AND
MEANINGLESS COUNTER FACTUALS.
>> IMAGINE, IF WE HAD BEGUN
EVACUATIONS IN JUNE OR JULY,
BRINGING IN THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN TROOPS AND EVACUATING
MORE THAN 120,000 PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CIVIL WAR?
STILL WOULD HAVE BEEN A RUSH TO
THE AIRPORT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THERE IS NO
E VAC, EVACUATION FROM THE END
OF A WAR THAT YOU CAN RUN
WITHOUT THE KINDS OF A THE
COMPLEXITIES, CHALLENGES AND
THREATS WE FACE.
NONE.
.
>> LAURA: AND A SLEW OF FORMER
TOP MILITARY OFFICIALS
VEHEMENTLY DISAGREED WITH HIM IN
A LETTER YESTERDAY, AND THEY
ECHOED WHAT I'VE BEEN SAYING ON
THIS SHOW.
DEFENSE SECRETARY LARRY ELDER
AUSTIN, CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEF'S MARK MILLEY, NEED TO GO
IMMEDIATELY.
THE NEARLY 90 RETIRED GENERALS
WROTE THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
DISASTER ARE ENORMOUS AND WILL
REVERB BROUGHT FOR DECADES OUR
ADVERSARIES ARE EMBOLDENED TO
MOVE AGAINST AMERICA DUE TO THE
WEAKNESS DISPLAYED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA GAVE THIS
LITTLE COVERAGE TODAY.
WHICH IS A TAD DIFFERENT FROM
HOW THEY REACTED ANY TIME SENIOR
MILITARY OR INTEL OFFICIALS
HAMMERED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT BACK TO OUR CURRENT
SHRINKING PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IT'S OBVIOUS FROM EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENED OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS THAT HE DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT THE OUTCOME HERE.
ONLY WHAT IT MEANS FOR HIS
PERSONAL POLL NUMBERS.
TAKE, FOR EXAMPLE, TODAY'S
REPORT ABOUT BIDEN'S JULY 23RD
PHONE CALL WITH FORMER AFGAN
PRESIDENT GHANI, WHO'S SINCE
FLED THE COUNTRY WITH A BUNCH OF
CASH.
NOW BIDEN WASN'T FOCUSED ON THE
FACTS ON THE GROUND AS MUCH AS
HOW IT WOULD LOOK IF THINGS
ENDED UP COLLAPSING.
IN MUCH OF THE CALL, BIDEN
FOCUSED ON WHAT HE CALLED THE
AFGAN GOVERNMENT'S PERCEPTION
PROBLEM.
I NEED NOT TELL YOU THE
PERCEPTION AROUND THE WORLD AND
IN PARTS OF AFGHANISTAN, I
BELIEVE, IS THAT THINGS ARE NOT
GOING WELL IN TERMS OF THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE TALIBAN.
THERE'S A NEED TO PROJECT A
DIFFERENT PICTURE.
WELL, ONCE AGAIN, HE AND HIS
TEAM ARE NOT EMERSED IN THE
DETAILS OF THE OPERATION, BUT,
INSTEAD, ON THE OPTICS AND THE
POSSIBLE POLITICAL FALLOUT.
DURING TRUMP'S ENTIRE TERM IN
OFFICE, ALL WE HEARD FROM THE
LEFT WAS HOW UNPRESIDENTIAL, HOW
DISRESPECTFUL HE WAS AND HOW HE
TRAMPLED ON POLITICAL NORMS.
REMEMBER ALL THAT?
BUT IT WAS MR. JOE BIDEN, THE
MOST EXPERIENCED PRESIDENT EVER,
WHO WAS ACTUALLY UNPRESIDENTIAL
AND DISRESPECTFUL AT THE DOVER
AIR FORCE BASE THIS PAST SUNDAY.
NOW, THINK ABOUT THIS.
ALL HE HAD TO DO WAS STAND THERE
AND SHOW GENUINE RESPECT AND
EMPATHY.
BUT WHAT HE'LL BE REMEMBERED FOR
IS LOOKING AT HIS WATCH AND SOME
PRE FUNKTORY COMMENTS TO
PARENTS.
>> IT DIDN'T GO WELL.
HE TALKED A BIT MORE ABOUT HIS
OWN SON THAN HE DID MY SON, AND
THAT DIDN'T SIT WELL WITH ME.
>> IN REFERENCE TO THE CHECKING
OF HIS WATCH, THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
JUST ONCE.
THAT HAPPENED ON EVERY SINGLE
ONE THAT CAME OUT OF THAT
AIRPLANE.
>> I COULDN'T LOOK AT HIM
ANYMORE AFTER THAT.
JUST CONSIDERING, ESPECIALLY,
THE TIME AND WHY WE WERE THERE.
IT WAS, I FOUND TO BE THE MOST
DISRESPECTFUL THING I'VE EVER
SEEN.
>> LAURA: THIS IS WHO JOE BIDEN
IS.
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN A SMALL-MINDED
GRIFTER WHO'S GENERALLY BEEN
CONSIDERED A SELF-PROMOTING
BUFFOON FOR MOST OF HIS CAREER.
THAT'S WHY HE WASN'T NOMINATED
IN 2016 AFTER BEING
VICE-PRESIDENT TO BARACK OBAMA
FOR EIGHT YEARS.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
OVER THE PAST 50 YEARS, BIDEN
NEVER SAID ANYTHING SIGNIFICANT
OR MEANINGFUL.
NEVER.
AND IT WAS THE SAME TODAY.
HIS SPEECH WAS SUPPOSED TO MARK
THE END OF OUR LONGEST WAR AND,
YET, HE LITERALLY SOUNDED LIKE
ANY RANDOM LIBERAL PUNDIT, LIKE
ONE OF THE JOYS, BAY HAR OR
REED, PETTY AND TRIVIAL.
EVEN TRUMP HATING BILL CRYSTAL.
>> END OF THE 20 YEAR WAR YOU
SHOULD GIVE A PRESIDENTIAL
SPEECH REFLECT ON WHAT IT MEANT.
INSTEAD IT WAS A DEFENSE OF
DEBATING POINTS IN A WAY ON WHAT
HE HAD DONE OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
THE IMPRESSION IS, HE'S NOT
QUITE LEADING THE MOMENT I
THINK.
>> LAURA: FIRST OF ALL, I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD EVER AGREE WITH
HIM AGAIN IN MY LIFE, NOR DID I
EVER THINK I WOULD PLAY A SOUND
BITE FROM BILL CRYSTAL BUT THERE
YOU HAVE IT, ANYTHING'S
POSSIBLE.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF JOE BIDEN'S
DISAPPEARING BEFORE OUR VERY
EYES.
HE'S JUST NOT ALL THAT RELEVANT.
THE REAL POLITICAL BAIT WILL
CONTINUE BETWEEN THE HARD LEFT
AND THE REST OF US WHO WANT TO
SAVE AMERICA FROM SOCIALISM AND
DECLINE.
AT LEAST THROUGH THE MIDTERMS,
DOMESTIC POLICY IS IN THE HANDS
OF SCHUMER AND PELOSI.
IMPORTANT FOREIGN POLICY
DECISIONS, GOING TO BE LARGELY
DETERMINED GOING FORWARD BY THE
EU AND CHINA.
CERTAINLY NOT BY THIS LITTLE
FELLOW.
THE FACT IS, THE REST OF THE
WORLD DOESN'T TAKE BIDEN
SERIOUSLY.
HIS OWN PEOPLE DON'T EVEN TAKE
HIM SERIOUSLY.
EITHER THEY DON'T LET HIM ANSWER
QUESTIONS, OR THEY CAREFULLY
CHOOSE THE REPORTERS HE'LL TAKE
QUESTIONS FROM.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THEY
GAVE ME A LIST HERE.
THE FIRST PERSON I WAS
INSTRUCTED TO CALL ON WAS KELLY
O'DONNELL OF NBC.
>> I'LL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS AND
AS USUAL, FOLKS, THEY GIVE ME A
LIST OF THE PEOPLE I'M GOING TO
CALL ON.
>> I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS BUT GO AHEAD.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, ON
AFGHANISTAN --
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ANSWER
AFGHANISTAN NOW.
>> CAN YOU --
>> CAN YOU GUARANTEE EVERY
AMERICAN WILL BE OUT?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN?
.
>> LAURA: CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
TODAY HE WOULDN'T ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
HE WAS JUST A WARM-UP ACT FOR
JEN PSAKI WHO OCCASIONALLY DOES
HER BEST TO SPIN BIDEN'S
INCO-HEREENS, BUT BIDEN TURNED
AROUND AND MADE SURE TO GRAB
THAT MASK.
GREAT JOB, JILL.
NO ONE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD HAS EVER CHANGED HIS OR
HER MIND ON ANYTHING AS A RESULT
OF A JOE BIDEN SPEECH, AND NO
ONE EVER WILL.
BUT AFTER THIS LATEST DISASTER,
NOT A SINGLE WORLD LEADER IS
PAYING ANY ATTENTION TO JOE
BIDEN ANYWAY.
HE AND AMERICA UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP IS DIMINISHED.
EVERYTHING HE TOUCHES GOES
SIDEWAYS.
AND THEN, HE ENDS UP GETTING
ANGRY AT YOU WHEN IT DOES.
HE BLAMES OTHERS, AS HE DID WITH
DONALD TRUMP TODAY WHILE
CLAIMING, AT THE SAME TIME, THAT
THE BUCK STOPS HERE.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT A REAL
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE DONE TODAY.
HE WOULD HAVE TAKEN ACTUAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT
UNFOLDED, AND HE WOULD HAVE
TREATED THE FAMILIES OF THE
FALLEN WITH REAL RESPECT AND
REAL COMPASSION.
HE WOULDN'T HAVE TALKED ABOUT
HIS OWN FAMILY OR HIS OWN LOSS.
HE WOULD HAVE FIRED EVERYONE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
CATASTROPHE.
HE WOULD REASSURE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT UNDER HIS WATCH, OUR
TROOPS WOULD NEVER AGAIN BE LEFT
AS SITTING DUCKS, AND THAT OUR
COUNTRY WOULD NEVER AGAIN BE
HUMILIATED, AS WE WERE IN KABUL.
AND A REAL PRESIDENT, A REAL
MAN, WOULDN'T HAVE LEFT 10% OF
AMERICANS BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN:
HE WOULDN'T HAVE LEFT ONE
BEHIND.
UNFORTUNATELY, FOR US, FOR
AMERICA, WE WON'T HAVE A REAL
PRESIDENT FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER
THRE